looting overwhelms california cities but
the experts say we shouldn't call it
looting a jury considers the ahmed
arbury case plus joe biden says that
it's not his fault oil prices are going
up i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first black friday is coming
up but you don't need to wait a couple
of days in order to start making your
money work for you this is particularly
true when it comes to your cell phone
bill which is one of your biggest
monthly bills why not save like half
when you go to puretalk usa pure talk
gives you killer 5g coverage on one of
the largest 5g networks in the country
and still saves the average family over
800 a year i made the switch the
coverage is excellent their us-based
customer service actually cares about
you and pure tax prices are pretty much
wholesale you've got a limited talk text
six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month you can keep your number keep your
phone or this month get black friday
prices on new phones like the iphone 12
for just 479
which is a fantastic fantastic deal
they've got a 30-day risk-free guarantee
you literally have nothing to lose
except for you know half off your
monthly bill go to puretalk.com shop for
the plan and phone that's right for you
then enter promo code shapiro you'll
save 50 off your first month and save on
a new phone that's puretalk.com promo
code shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless some restrictions apply see
site for details and you could be saving
a ton of money with pure talk so why
exactly would you insist on paying your
money to like verizon or att when you
could be using their network for the
same exact coverage go to puretalk.com
go check them out right now alrighty so
over in california we are seeing the
wages of reality the left convinces
itself that if it simply wishes for
things hard enough and claps loud enough
then tinkerbell will live but that is
not the way things work when it comes to
criminal justice issues according to the
uk daily mail san francisco bay has now
been hit by a third day of brazen
looting with a gang of thieves filmed
smashing cases at a jewelry store and
emptying them as staff screamed in
terror the latest incident happened at a
sam's jewelers store at the southland
mall in hayward around 5 30 p.m sunday
evening and was caught on camera robbers
were apparently part of a gang of around
40 to 50 teens who entered the mall
wielded hammers to smash display cases
at sam's before making off with the
goods dramatic footage shot from a
nearby store showed shop workers
screaming in fear as the disturbing
scene unfolded also on sunday another
gang of looters snatched garments from
upmarket yoga brand lululemon's san jose
store i mean they need their they need
their pants
they need those um they need those yoga
pants
and uh apparently it would be
totally terrible to point out that folks
are looting really bad to point out that
the folks are are looting here because
if you use the word looting then this
implies that black people are doing
eluding well in this video
black people are apparently doing the
looting and there's nothing wrong with
saying they are looting they're
literally smashing cases at a jewelry
store and then just grabbing stuff and
running
and the race is only relevant in
describing suspects because when you
want to catch suspects you actually have
to use their physical descriptors also
the media's refusal to announce the the
race of particular criminals is an
ongoing thing in american media coverage
when it comes to american media coverage
you will notice that any time there's a
white criminal he's described
immediately as a white criminal any time
it is a black criminal the person is
just described as a criminal and that is
because the media don't wish to purvey
the notion that a disproportionate
number of black people are committing
crimes even if unfortunately a
disproportionate number of black people
are committing crimes they think that
this will give fodder to racists who
think that there are natural differences
between black and white that lead to the
crime
all of that is the media attempting to
read too much into how crime is actually
covered but again the fact of the matter
is this is looting and the people who
are doing it should be prosecuted by the
way you know who is saying this not me
al sharpton this is where you insert
graphic
of that onion story worst person you
know makes good point here's al sharpton
a terrible human being who has
incentivized actual rioting in the past
saying yeah you know it's really people
who are kind of limousing liberals who
are interested in in letting these sorts
of of criminals off the hook
a guy or a lady stealing a louis vuitton
bag is not somebody that needs social
uplifting this is somebody that is
really causing us more of a problem he's
latte liberals that justify this this
has nothing to do with poverty this has
nothing to do with you couldn't get a
job these are people that can go back in
the neighborhoods where louis vuitton
bag is not unusual and they can just fit
in and many of it for gag and they hurt
the cause of those that want criminal
justice reform
wow al sharpton saying the same thing
but here's the thing the left has lost
it so much that even al sharpton is like
you guys are way too much for me al
sharpton
like sorry guys i'm not on this
bandwagon on saturday video posted to
twitter showed a swarm of robbers caught
on security cameras stealing
prescriptions from wellspring pharmacy
in oakland at around 7 30 p.m pharmacy
employees sped up the footage to show
dozens of people running through the
store to grab boxes of drugs off the
shelves before quickly moving out it's
unclear what drugs were stolen staff say
customers whose meds were stolen will
still be able to collect replacement
meds that have been ordered in store
employees told kgo tv reporter diane lim
they were overwhelmed and devastated by
the brazen theft that's a small drug
store it doesn't have the same resources
as chains like cvs or walgreens but by
the way it is important to note that a
lot of these chain stores have pulled
out of san francisco because of the
crime right this has happened in a lot
of high crime areas around the country
target has shut its doors in a variety
of locales where crime is high
in fact best buy which is a major chain
the ceo cory berry said theft is a
growing problem at the company stores
they're implementing added security
measures to safeguard employees and
shoppers barry said on a call with
analysts this is traumatizing for our
associates it's unacceptable we're doing
everything we can to try and create as
safe
as possible an environment
apparently best buy said that they are
actually seeing a stock drop because of
the crime surge
apparently it's hitting best buy's
profits it could hurt its ability to
retain and attract more employees in a
tight labor market
apparently some incidents involve
individuals bringing a weapon like a gun
or a crowbar
barry's comments come on the heels of a
string of retail thefts in san francisco
the targeted louis vuitton a burberry
store a jewelry store bloomingdale's
walgreens on saturday a nordstrom
department store near san francisco's
ransacked in what police described as a
smash-and-grab incident
and it's not just restricted to san
francisco by the way nordstrom's in la
was also hit so this is over by the
grove which is one of the most upscale
areas of los angeles it was also hit
during the riots by the way i remember
the the so-called peaceful protest last
year that burned half the cars on
melrose boulevard they went to the grove
as well as a place that i used to go
with my kids to hang out and grow it's a
really nice area in los angeles but this
is the second time inside of about a
year and a half that it's now been
looted
so things are going really well at these
at these major cities these major cities
and again it is not just san francisco
in los angeles louisiana was hit saks
fifth avenue on rodeo drive was damaged
roto drive is like the nicest area in
los angeles and you'll recall that last
year during the black lives matter riots
they actually shut down rodeo drive at
1pm in the middle of the riots because
they had to give people space to to
smash things
beverly hills said police said officers
responded sunday to reports of a window
smash near the 200 block of rodeo drive
when they arrived they located two
storefronts that had their windows
smashed the damaged storefronts included
louis vuitton and sacks fifth avenue
and as we say nordstrom's got hit as
well
so things are going beautifully for the
left like they're going they're going
wonderfully for left and and this is a
left-wing thing it really is it's a
left-wing thing because they've decided
that being soft on crime is just another
form of equity we'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about the
possibility of death death unfortunately
comes for all of us let's say that
you're just a teacher from middle
america and you're drafted into the u.s
army it's world war ii and you're sent
on it i'm kind of an insane mission to
save one guy and you make it through
d-day you make it through the storming
of the beaches you make it all the way
overland to a battle scary area finally
you get there you've lost half your
company finally you get there and uh and
very end
things go wrong and you get to make a
dramatic speech but as you're making the
dramatic speech you're also thinking
ma'am should have gotten policy genius
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why compare well you
could save 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
he could save 1300 or more per year on
life insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies the licensed experts
and policy genius work for you not the
insurance companies so you can trust
them to help you navigate every step of
the shopping and buying process that
kind of service has earned policy genius
thousands of five-star reviews across
trustpilot and google and eligible
applicants can get covered in as little
as a week thanks to an award-winning
policy option swapping the standard
medical exam requirement for a simple
phone call head over to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes work out how much
life insurance coverage you need policy
genius handles all the rest go to policy
genius.com shapiro get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important to get it
right okay so
the left wants to treat this sort of
stuff with kid gloves according to kgo
in san francisco quote bay area police
departments have called what happened at
various retail stores this weekend
looting we saw similar crimes happen in
the wake of the george floyd protests
but are the past weekend's crimes truly
considered looting
race and social justice reporter julian
glover is here to give us some context
of looting
um first of all race and social justice
reporter is
a great title for propagandists
you don't need a race and social justice
reporter unless you're a propaganda
outlet
what you because you're now breaking
people down according to immutable
characteristics which i thought was the
definition of racism and you don't need
a social justice reporter because social
justice is activism social justice is
just a way of using the word justice and
twisting it away from actual justice as
soon as you add a modifier to the word
justice you're toast
when people talk about distributive
justice they don't mean justice what
they mean is some people want other
people's stuff
when people talk about social justice
they don't mean that we should treat
each individual in accordance with what
they deserve they mean that groups
should be treated in accordance with
what the groups deserve and here's the
thing about groups they don't deserve
anything groups are just groups
okay but
says the race and social justice
reporter julian glover quote as the bay
area grapples with a wave of seemingly
organized smash and grab robberies this
weekend policing and journalism analysts
are cautioning against the use of the
term looting oh are they who are these
who are these experts these acts it's
always great you know the credentialing
in journalism is a real issue so it used
to be that journalism was a process
right you committed an act of journalism
if you followed the process if you
verified your sources if you went
through the hard slog of ensuring that
what you're reporting was true you had
committed an act of journalism then
journalism became a credentialed degree
and now if you have the degree you're
considered a journalist even though
you're not actually reporting anything
or doing anything in accordance with the
journalistic process
and the process of how journalism became
sort of a credentialed position like
being a doctor
as opposed to just a person who reports
is kind of astonishing at the beginning
of the 20th century the the reporters
that you saw were people who kind of
were high school grads who had a
a battered fedora that's what you see in
all the movies from the 30s battered hat
guy who is just
walking the pavement seeking a story gum
shoeing it
and then there's a movement toward okay
we need we need a better standard of
journalism it's led by a guy named
walter lippman the idea was we need a
better standard of journalism so we
don't have as much muck breaking we
don't have as much false material
getting out there that wasn't the wrong
idea the problem is then you started to
get schools that determined that you
would learn the process there and then
the degree itself became the target so
now you graduate from college you go to
nyu school of journalism you come out as
a good little liberal and then
you don't actually have to pay attention
to the normal processes of journalism or
you know verify information you just
find a guy you like and the guy you like
is the expert and then you quote the
expert to say exactly what you would
want to say if you were the expert it's
amazing
san francisco police chief bill scott
said the louis vuitton store was
burglarized and looter looted the
burberry in westfield mall was
burglarized and looted chief scott was
detailing his department's response to a
wave of potentially organized retail
thefts and burglaries netting a million
dollars in stolen luxury goods but say
the experts this is bad this is bad
according to the california penal code
what we saw was not looting the penal
code defines looting as theft or
burglary during a state of emergency
local emergency or evacuation order to
some the distinction may be small but
lorenzo boyd phd professor of criminal
justice and community policing at the
university of new haven and a retired
veteran police officer emphasized words
matter
looting is a term we typically use when
people of color or urban dwellers are
doing something we tend not to use that
term for other people when they do the
exact same thing
um
well
no that's not true if somebody smashes
and grabs at my local jewelry store i
don't care what race they are that is
looting
okay but but again the idea is that
somehow you're doing black people a
favor if you don't use the word looting
okay so does it change if i just say
that they engaged in mass theft and
burglary at these stores by the way we
don't even know that all these people
are
are black we know in certain situations
because we have video that they are
black
but in some of these cases
we have no idea who the criminals are
okay but this is all part and parcel of
a broader take on criminal justice which
is if we ignore the problem in favor of
stupid
band-aids that the problem goes away
or that we misidentify the root of the
problem
so on the one hand you have the semantic
change as well you know if we don't call
it looting then maybe that will end the
looting because then we won't have
the racist beliefs of america that black
people are disproportionately looting
and this will end systemic racism if we
don't use the word looting we had the
same sort of stupid crap in los angeles
south central los angeles was widely
known as one of the high crime centers
of los angeles for my entire childhood
it's where the riots broke out during
rodney king etc and the city council of
los angeles decided that because there
was such a stigma attached to south
central they would call it south l.a did
that end the crime rates
no because it turns out that south la
was still south central
but it did make some people feel better
for like half a second didn't solve any
of the problems so there's the semantic
game playing where it's oh well you know
if we don't call it looting if we call
it south la well that probably ends the
problem because then the stigma goes
away and the stigma is the problem
and then there is the deeper point which
is well you know the root of criminality
and disproportionate criminality in
certain minority communities that the
root of that is deep-seated american
racism and racism in the criminal
justice system and the only way to heal
that is by pursuing equity in criminal
justice and the way we pursue equity in
criminal justice is by letting criminals
roam free if they are of a particular
race we need to make sure that only a
proportionate number of criminals are
actually arrested by racial group now
this is a very stupid way of doing
things because it turns out that you're
not saying innocent people shouldn't be
arrested we all agree innocent people
shouldn't be arrested what you're saying
is that if too many black people are
arrested then this means there's a
problem with the system itself of
arresting people
which is the same thing that we are
seeing right now with regard to testing
if too many black people are doing not
well on the sat or act the ucs just stop
using the sat or act
if you just change the metric then
magically the problem goes away
right if you
if you
count certain things as not things
then everything is equal outcome just
change the measure itself
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because this goes to how criminal
prosecution is done in major american
cities get to that in just a moment
first
you know there are a lot of guys who are
suffering from erectile dysfunction it
is not particularly rare 52 percent of
dudes age 40 to 70 experience some form
of ed well if you've got edie you've
just been sitting around and thinking
well maybe it'll go away instead just go
get it solved go to getroman.com right
now speak to a u.s licensed healthcare
professional about erectile dysfunction
get 15 bucks off your first month of
treatment you need to make sure that
your life is running smoothly and that
does involve making sure that your
medical conditions are taken care of
with roman you get a free online
evaluation ongoing care for reptile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy of your own home it's completely
confidential it's totally discreet no
big logos no labels on the packages a us
licensed healthcare professional will
work with you to find the best treatment
plan if medication is appropriate it
ships you free with two-day shipping the
whole process is straightforward
convenient and discreet getting started
is simple just go to getroman.com ben
complete an online visit take care of
your ed without leaving your home
complete an online visit today connect
with a us licensed healthcare
professional and get it taken care of go
to getroman.com
bend today if you are prescribed get 15
off your first month of ed treatment
make sure you're ready to have
confidence in control this season roman
ready head on over to getroman.com ben
today if you're prescribed at 15 bucks
off your first month of ed treatment
okay so
all of this sort of equity based
nonsense gets translated into really
really bad public policy
as we have seen right this is what we
just saw in waukesha wisconsin where a
career criminal with a rap sheet longer
than the first five books of the bible
was just released on one thousand
dollars bail
after having been arrested for using his
car to attempt to run over his
girlfriend
and uh he was arrested released on a
thousand dollars bail and then according
to court charging documents deliberately
drove his car down a street with a
parade filled with children and older
women
and the media have reported this because
again you don't want to report this
situation for what it is which is a
career criminal committing an act of
mass murder you don't want to do that
because it might you know imply things
it is it is amazing how studiously the
media are avoiding talking about this
guy's political views i don't know what
this guy's motives were you don't know
what this guy's motives were i'm curious
about the guy's motives aren't you
i think we're we're usually curious
about the motives of people who commit
mass murder because we want to know what
drove them to do it the media are
studiously incurious about all of this
and in fact they're very angry if you
try to bring up
any indicator of what the guy could have
been thinking andy no who does excellent
or better reporting than most of the
criminal justice social justice race
reporters in the mainstream media and he
started going through his social media
and posting stuff from his social media
and the daily beast then ran a story
about how evil andy no was to point this
out so we just got a year-long
a year-long false
reporting master clinic from the
mainstream media and while kyle
writtenhouse is a white supremacist he
isn't and there's no evidence that he is
but if you do so much as look at this
guy's facebook post the waukesha
murderer if you if you
so much as look at his tick tock then
this means that you are upholding white
supremacy or some such nonsense
and well the the people who are in
charge of the system want the system
this way it's not like they're hiding
the ball so john chisholm is the
milwaukee county d.a
back in 2007
he was elected
and he immediately started advocating
for lower cash bonds for criminals
in 2007 chisholm told the milwaukee
journal sentinel this is a direct quote
quote
is there going to be an individual i
divert or put into a treatment program
who's going to go out and kill somebody
you bet guaranteed it's guaranteed to
happen it does not invalidate the
overall approach
so in other words yeah i'm going to put
criminals back on the street but you
know
if some people die i guess some people
die again all in the name of social
justice
meanwhile over in san francisco where
smash and grabs are so bad the looting
is so bad that stores are literally
shutting their doors because they cannot
afford to remain open they're operating
at a loss
chase a bowden was elected in 2019 this
is the socialist d.a
in san francisco and this is a guy who
has been pretty obvious about his desire
to not enforce the law
we don't want to make mistakes we want
to move carefully and judiciously so
we're going to be working really hard
over the next couple of months to put in
place that transition plan to listen to
law enforcement leaders to community
leaders to merchants to go around the
city and really sit down with every
stakeholder we can and make sure their
voice is being heard as we go about
transforming san francisco's approach to
criminal justice
okay well they changed san francisco's
approach to criminal justice all right
now you should shoot heroin into your
feet on the street and crap on the
street corner and in your off hours
smash and grab at the louisiana but this
is all for social justice so you know
what reality as i say always wins i root
for reality right natural law is based
on the idea that human reason is capable
of apprehending the world and then
making rules to live in concert with
realities of the world i'm a natural law
believer not only as a religious person
but as a sort of philosophical approach
to life which means you have to have
some baseline respect for the realities
of the world the left has no respect for
the realities of the world the idea is
if you transform the system you
transform human beings well they
transformed the system in these areas it
turns out they did not transform the
human beings the human beings are
exactly the same their incentive
structures just change the incentive
structure used to be that if you smash
and grab at louis vuitton you might end
up in jail for a very long time in
california if you do it repeatedly
you're going to end up under the three
strikes law maybe spending the rest of
your life in prison but
no longer now we have changed our
approach to criminal justice because if
we change how cosmic justice is
allocated in thomas soule's phraseology
then we are like gods well there's only
one problem you can't change human
nature human nature is what human nature
is and when criminals feel like they can
do what they want without any threat of
punishment they just go ahead and do it
the fact that this is in any way some
sort of shock to people is astonishing
to me and democrats who embrace this are
br they're they're going to reap the
whirlwind we are watching democrats in
nearly every area of american life
particularly progressive areas embracing
1970s style policy and then expecting
1985 style results that's not the way
this works you're not going to get 1997
decreases in crime if you embrace 1972
criminal justice policies it turns out
that policy has rather major
ramifications for things like crime
right the reason that new york went from
a bleephole country in the 1980s and it
really was i mean you had like open
prostitution in times square to
disneyland is because of massive broken
windows policing in new york city under
rudy giuliani and then under michael
bloomberg
but apparently progressives have decided
to abandon all of that because after all
you have to make sure that if if too
many people of a particular skinhew are
getting arrested
the problem is not that too many people
of a particular skinhew are committing
crimes the problem is the system the
problem is deep-seated racial injustice
now again this is not to deny that there
can be historic causes for current day
events history has a long tail but the
only way that you break the chain of
history is by not committing crimes and
punishing people who do that is the only
way that you break the chain of history
if you want more investment in
low-income black areas there needs to be
lower crime the only way to get to lower
crime is not to push and moan about
16-19 the only way to get lower crime is
put more cops in those areas and arrest
more criminals end of story
that does not mean 1619 didn't happen it
doesn't mean that there isn't a
historical legacy that leads to
disparate results it does mean the only
way to actually fix the problem is to
fix the problem but the left is not
interested in fixing problems the left
is interested in tearing down the system
they don't care about they don't care
about fixing problems they are only
interested in the narrative this is why
nicole hannah jones for example the
founder of the 6019 project and she says
that 1776 is not a good explanatory
model for the world 1619 is better
explanatory model for the world here's
the thing liberty is the only
explanatory model that also allows you
to take measures to preserve safety and
protect property
the model that nicole hannah jones
proposes on a moral level is that if a
group that you're a member of has been
victimized in the past
it's not about solving the problem
anymore now it's about the cosmic
justice of you should be allowed to do
whatever the hell you want apparently
according to nicole hannon jones we have
to restructure the system for equal
results despite non-equal activity
taking place in everyday life
the narrative of 1776 does not explain
the insurrection on the capitol in
january it doesn't explain george floyd
and why a white police officer
could feel that he could kill a man in
front of witnesses and would not have to
worry about facing any consequences and
it certainly doesn't explain why we have
a political party right now that is uh
trying to instate minority rule that is
the legacy of 1619.
[Music]
right everything that's happening right
now is the legacy of 6019 the only thing
that's the legacy of the 1619 project
right now are the riots
our smash and grabs we're not allowed to
call it looting
our criminal justice policies geared
toward allowing criminals to run free
and wreck cities by the way
disproportionately harming other
minorities
that's the legacy of the 6019 project
that's their goal they don't want 1776
because 1776 means liberty and liberty
also comes along with duty and personal
responsibility and that is not what they
want because duty and personal
responsibility might end with disparate
results and that they can't allow
okay coming up we need to get to the
ahmeda arbory trial it's not a trial of
ahmedabary obviously it's of the
mcdaniels we're going to get to that in
just one moment because if that case
goes sideways for the prosecution what
you're gonna hear is it's systemic
american racism the case is a little
more complicated than that so i'm just
gonna i don't know how that case is
gonna come down but it's important that
you know the facts because the media
have been notably absent in reporting
the facts first let's talk about your
safety and security at home this holiday
season deck the halls walls windows and
doors with the best deals of the year on
the award-winning ring alarm i'm sure we
all know about the ring video doorbell
by now did you know that ring makes an
award-winning alarm ring alarm is a
powerful affordable whole home security
system you can easily install yourself
so whether you're running across town or
across the country this busy season you
and your loved ones can rest easy
knowing that your home is protected it's
more than just security ring alarm
protects your home from flood freeze and
fire as well plus it's much cheaper than
those other companies for what they
charge for one month you get an entire
year of ring alarm with professional
monitoring right now for the best deals
of the year on ring alarm go to ring.com
forward slash ben
i use my ring app all the time a bunch
of little kids running around the house
i got my little baby the squishy baby
and uh she is mobile she's very very
mobile at this point and sometimes i'll
be playing with her and then i will get
distracted by my phone i look around and
the baby's gone like uh oh this is when
ring app comes in very very handy this
holiday season like the halls walls
windows and doors with the best deals of
the year on the award-winning ring alarm
go to ring.com forward slash ben get a
great deal on a ring alarm security kit
today that is ring.com forward slash ben
go check them out right now okay so
meanwhile in the narrative that america
is systemically racist so we have the
kyle written house trial where the left
continues to maintain by the way that
kyle rittenhouse was a white supremacist
in fact jen sake from the white house
yesterday was asked directly by steve
ducey whether the president of the
united states would be apologizing to
kyle renthouse for including him an ad
in september of 2020 linking him with
white supremacy here is jen saki's
terrible non-answer
this is about a campaign video released
last year that used president trump's
own words during a debate as he refused
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups you know what we've seen
are the tragic consequences of that when
people think it's okay to take the law
into their own hands instead of allowing
law enforcement to do its job and the
president believes in condemning hatred
division and violence that's exactly
what was done in that video
so um
yeah uh that is not a good answer and uh
i hope that joe biden finds himself in
court having to explain why he defamed a
17 year old
but the narrative must be preserved at
all class so we are moving directly on
from the written house case to the to
the
case and the killing of ahmedabary so
you'll remember the case of ahmedabary
is actually a little complicated it's a
little more complicated than you've been
allowed to believe the original
narrative that you were told by the
media always by the way in these cases
wait like a week for more facts to come
out the original narrative gets set and
then the media just holds to it so in
the written house case the original
narrative by the media was crazed white
killer crosses state lines with guns in
an attempt to murder people who are
rioting on behalf of blm and but not
rioting peacefully protesting these were
civil rights activists like mlk okay
that was the media's account and they
still are holding to it and the media
are still pretending that that's a thing
the media account right now that's being
set by the way in waukesha is that it
was completely non-politically motivated
we have no idea whether it was or
whether it wasn't but they were saying
already they know it was not and also
that um that the suv attacked people
right it's just the ford escape attack
people you gotta watch out for those
four escapes you're walking down the
block
you see a ford escape man turn and go
the other way although you wouldn't want
a car profile i don't car profile
because that's a little bit anti-car
it's it's it's race car it's racist car
anyway um the the suv's the problem well
now the narrative's been set on arbory
for a while so the narrative originally
was ahmedabary was jogging through a
white neighborhood jogging you know
going for a job and uh he was tracked
down by some white racists and then he
was roadblocked he attempted to get
through and they shot him
right that was the original narrative
it's a little more complex than that as
it turns out
and the complexity of georgia law means
that these defendants could
theoretically get off and if they get
off you're going to hear people claiming
loudly that this is american racism
no this case this fact pattern is not
particularly clear it just is not
by the way i i have to point out here
that there is like an actual black
militia standing outside the courthouse
right now in georgia
for the for the trial of mcdaniels and
um threatening violence fairly openly
can you imagine if a white militia
showed up in kenosha wisconsin to
protest the kyle rittenhouse trial
and how the media would have covered
that now if these people have licenses
to carry and they're doing something
legal then fine i'm not saying that what
they're doing is illegal i am saying
that uh if the races will
the media like to play if the race is
reverse if the races were reversed i can
guarantee you this would be getting a
lot more media
coverage need to look at what happens to
the
written house
what's going on right now that was no
justice but at the end of the day it
takes us to do the right thing to get
justice in america for ma
for all the other people who died
because of systemic states racism and
police brutality
we need justice
okay so great um what exactly happened
in this case it's in dispute okay so
last week there was actual defense
testimony that sort of makes this a
little bit more dicey so here's the
thing america was not jogging in the
neighborhood amenaberry was trespassing
okay he might have been involved in
burglary
this is the case that the defense is
going to make and you should know that's
the case the defense is going to make so
that if
the guys are let off i mean if the
defendants in this case are let off
it is not purely about american style
racism
it could be about
the alternative fact pattern that allows
for reasonable doubt because in this
country you have to be proved to be the
the
criminal beyond a reasonable doubt
travis mcmichael's defense attorney said
that his client had reasonable
and probable grounds of suspicion to
follow the 25 year old arbor in his
truck because he believed he was a
burglar
he added that although aubry was not
armed with a weapon mcmichael said he'd
reached into his shirt as if for a
weapon also
he was armed with his fist but that's
not really the question once you reach
for the gun and it's a struggle over the
gun you might have mutual self-defense
right if you're carrying a gun and i
attack you and i try to grab your gun
then it's not a question of whether i'm
ironed or not we're both going for the
gun
okay the question here really is not
even about the moment of the shooting
and that really is not the question
because the question is whether
mcmichaels had a reasonable
justification in trying to stop arbory
or whether they did not if they were not
attempting to stop him for a reasonable
purpose
then anything that follows is their
fault and this is the essence of the
case the essence of the case is if they
were following arbory for no reason
because he was a black guy and then they
tried to roadblock him and he attacked
them and they shot him
that means that they are guilty of
murder
and false imprisonment by the way under
georgia law if however they had a
rational and probable justification if
they if they had like 51 justification
to following him reasonable suspicion
that he was a felon
and under georgia citizens arrest law
anything that follows now becomes mutual
self-defense essentially arberry
attacking because he thinks that these
are guys trying to run him down you
understand why he did what he did and
also once he goes for the gun
then the person holding the gun has to
do what he has to do to maintain control
of the gun
okay so
this is the entire issue and so remember
originally the story was that arbury was
just there doing nothing right he was
just jogging then the story changed
which is well he was walking around an
empty house here's the thing according
to
testimony witness testimony and video
testimony and video evidence arbury had
been casing this house that was under
construction and was nearly done
repeatedly like there is a lot of
footage
of arbory trespassing in this particular
house now trespass is a misdemeanor
which still would not justify them
trying to arrest him it would have to be
felony trespass would have to be felony
burglary okay so the question is did
they have reasonable not did he commit a
felony did they have reasonable
suspicion that he had committed a felony
so the person's house that he was
apparently trespassing in
was a guy named larry english whose
house was being built and some equipment
had been stolen from the house that
amounts to felony burglary in the state
of georgia if arboret committed it
unclear whether aubrey was the guy who's
stealing the equipment but he was going
to the site over and over and over again
apparently here was some of the trespass
video of ahmedabary at this particular
site
security cameras caught several people
going into this home under construction
in the same neighborhood the owner
shared this video today of a man in the
home in december it's not clear if this
could be arberry but the owner believes
the same man entered the home on
february 11th a glenn county police
report details officers arriving but not
finding anyone trespassing
okay so
the police were called one of the police
officers who's called a guy named robert
rash and he says i was going to come and
i was going to uh give arbory a trespass
warning if that was harbory
if you made contact with the uh now
deceased homicide victim
your intent was to what
identify him
okay then trespass him
and
if that's what mr english it's it's
ultimately his decision and it does
happen somehow some homeowners some
business owners they just say tell them
to leave i don't want you to trespass
and just tell him to leave and don't
come back and it's ultimately larry
english's decision
okay and then robert rash said something
that actually cuts in favor of the
defense he said i told the entire
neighborhood about arbory trespassing
including the mcmichaels okay so now meg
michaels are suspicious that there is
a guy
who looks like arbory trespassing on the
property and they know that property has
been stolen from that particular house
and so now you're starting to see the
possibility of reasonable grounds for
trying to make a citizen's arrest okay
so here is rash saying that he told the
whole neighborhood about this situation
this is not just a secret the police
knew this is something everybody knew
where did you encounter greg mcmichael
on december 20th 2019. he was in his
front yard
of his property at 2 30. he's still the
source we spoke
uh talked to him in reference to the
the unidentified black male down at 220
219 excuse me you have 220 stitilla
drive
we talked about him continually to come
onto the property not being able to
figure out who he is
i told
mr mcmichael that i had
somewhat canvassed the neighborhood
talked to different people nobody knew
who he was
okay and then this officer testifies
again this is an officer for the georgia
police force he says that he told larry
english was the owner of the house to
tell mcmichaels to watch the property
okay so it wasn't like michaels was just
kind of wandering around and then he saw
this he told him watch the property he
told the property owner tell mcmichaels
who's a former cop to watch the property
mr michael asked me to pass on his phone
number to mr english and that he was
lives right down the road if he had
needed in to calling and that's when i
sent the text to
mr english that greg michael
was a retired d.a a police officer and
an investigator from the district
attorney's office
okay so the defense this is their case
their case is that arbory was
allegedly a burglar
committing a felony or at least the ming
michaels had reason to believe that he
was a burglar committing a felony that
there was video showing him in the house
that a police officer had warned the
entire neighborhood that this
person was was burglarizing the house or
at least was trespassing and might be
burglarizing that the police had told
the owner of the house to call
mcmichaels in case he saw on video
somebody doing this
and then michael's found out about it
and then tracked him down because that
starts to look like maybe reasonable
grounds for defense i'm not saying that
it is reasonable grounds for a defense
i'm saying that you can see why a jury
might reach that conclusion if in fact
that is a conclusion the jury reaches
without ever having to access the
question of race okay here is the the
here are some of the lawyers for the
mcmichaels making the case this would be
jason sheffield and laura hogue making
the case as to what arberry was doing
that day remember the entire case hinges
on whether it was reasonable for the
michaels to try to effectuate a
citizen's arrest if yes then whatever
happens is no longer murder if no then
what happens is first degree murder and
false imprisonment
constitute the offense of burglary it's
not necessary
that a break-in happened that something
gets broken
if you recall all the questions by the
state of the witnesses well
was anything broken was a window broken
was a door broken
[Music]
that's not what's required for the law
those questions are meaningless
and they are red herrings burglary is a
felony
entering a dwelling place without
authority
with the intent to commit a theft in
there
okay and uh and hogue went on
to talk about this she said aubry was
involved in criminality he was not an
innocent guy who's just jogging down the
street which of course again the media
botched the story at the beginning
there's no question the original story
was that he was just an innocent guy who
was jogging around now again he may have
been innocent of a felony and the
mcmichaels may not have known that he
was committing a felony right that's
gonna be the prosecution's case here
they were just a bunch of racist white
guys who decided to track down a black
guy who's in the neighborhood
but um
according to the defense lawyers it
seems like and according to that witness
testimony at least there's a per se case
a sort of prima facie case that they had
some understanding that this guy
likely was committing a crime or may
have been committing a crime
ahmad arbury was not an innocent victim
plundering through larry english's house
on february 23rd
just as he wasn't an innocent victim
all the other nights
like october
25th
or november 18th
or december 15th or february 11th
is he the person responsible for
stealing larry english's expensive boat
equipment i don't know we don't know
no one investigated that
but can anyone reasonably
believe
that a mod arbory was just
doing a lookie-loo
on those nights
this is gonna be the question okay so
the only reason that i bring this up is
because if this verdict comes down the
way the media don't want it to come down
then what you're gonna hear is america's
systemically racist just like kyle
rittenhouse and they're going to
manufacture a narrative about it i think
it's important for you to know the facts
of the case which go it could go either
way right it looks a lot like the
shelving case but which looks like it
does not necessarily have much to do
with racism by the way the prosecution
in this case did not make it about
racism this is important to note as well
the prosecution did not
even admit into evidence the idea that
mcmichaels did this because arbor was
black instead what they said is that the
mcmichaels were overzealous guardians of
their community and they just were
looking for an opportunity to go out and
play vigilante essentially they did not
make the case the prosecution that the
mcmichaels did this because barbara's
race if the prosecution didn't do that
how was the media making it all about
that this would make
how many cases can we have where there's
not even an allegation that it's really
at root about racism made in court and
yet the media makes it about race right
written house was about race clearly was
not about race the people who were shot
were white chauvin and george floyd it
was the biggest race story in the
country there was not even an allegation
made in court that derek chovin killed
george floyd because george floyd was
black that allegation was not made
because there was no evidence to it and
now the media are making it that the
mcmichaels killed arbory because our
berry was black that allegation really
was not made in court
the reason i point this out is because
whichever way the verdict goes you
should understand that fact patterns do
not match what the media tells you about
the fact patterns because the media have
an agenda and that agenda will be
pursued no matter the underlying fact
pattern right looting is not looting
because
if the wrong people are doing the
looting you wouldn't want to label it
looting it might create stigma and race
cases that are not race cases are still
race cases because we have to maintain
the 16 19 narrative even when it doesn't
match a particular fact pattern already
coming up we'll get to joe biden trying
to do something about rising at gas
prices after having helped create the
rising gas prices we'll get to that
momentarily first let's talk about your
sleep quality so
i just got to tell you the best sheets
on the market bowling branch period end
of story this cyber week bowlin branch
is offering their best deal of the
entire year if last night's sleep wasn't
as good as it could be their sheets
could make all the difference with
bowling branch you get the best sleep of
your life with their highest quality
organic cotton sheets the signature hemp
sheets those are the all-time bestseller
they are beloved for many reasons like
how they get softer with every single
wash they're buttery soft lightweight
they're made with 100 organic cotton
weave that feels incredible in all
seasons they come in a wide range of
colors and sizes from twin up to
california king completely toxin free
fair trade certified we love our bowling
branch sheets so much that we had other
sheets and uh yeah those are in the
garbage now or given to salvation army
those sheets were no good bull and
branch that's the stuff you want this
cyber week give your loved ones the best
sleep of their lives or treat yourself
with bull and branch their holiday
packaging famously soft sheets blankets
pillows and more make a difference
everyone will feel get 25 off from
november 23rd through december 2nd with
their best offer of the year at bull and
branch dot com that's 25 off at b-o-l-l
and branch dot com exclusions may apply
all right in just a second we'll get to
the joe biden of it all first
got big announcement i said like in 2015
we were gonna have a merch store here at
daily wire and everyone's like don't say
it don't say it because we don't we do
it's here that's just ahead of my time
the daily wire shop is live it's ready
for all your extremely important
christmas and hanukkah needs yes you
heard that right daily wire merch it's
here head to dailywire.com shop to check
out all of the brilliant collections
like the do not comply tees or the let's
go brandon tailgate gear or my personal
line of merch yes indeed my personal
line of merch you can get a my wife's a
doctor t-shirt you can also get a fax
t-shirt with this extraordinarily
beautiful punim anyone can shop at the
dailyweara store but only dailywear
members get special discounts up to 20
off
members also received access to shop
exclusive items like signed copies of
candace owns his book blackout which
will only be available for a limited
amount of time members can now also
purchase the iconic leftist tiers
tumbler we've never made the tumblr
available to buy before we've only got
very limited quantities at the rate
they're selling they will be gone by
black friday that means if you want to
give the tumbler as a gift this
christmas you should get yours right now
head on over to dailywire.com
shop to get a little something for
everyone on your list who will not
comply and if you're not yet a member
sign up right now at dailywire.com
subscribe enter code dw35 you had 35 off
your membership all the perks you
wouldn't otherwise
that deal ends tomorrow make sure you
grab that discount while you still can
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile oil prices across
the nation are way too high and that is
because the biden administration has
made the decision they don't want to
tell you about this decision because
it's unfortunate but they made the
decision that they are in the pocket of
the climate change crowd and this means
that it is good that your oil prices are
high they are paying too much of the
pump that is a good thing they've said
this sort of stuff before by the way
pretty openly and pretty clearly they
want the price of gas to go up so that
you are incentivized to do more
expensive forms of energy
all of this to save the earth and
they're saying it pretty clearly right
now i mean joe biden for example he says
we're reducing reliance on oil it's good
you know yeah i mean the gas is
expensive but that's we're reducing our
reliance on oil right now isn't that
isn't that a good thing here's the thing
we were oil independent under the last
president then joe biden came in he
killed keystone xl he started banning
oil leases on federal land and uh now
we're not anymore so that is indeed his
fault he says but that's a good thing
it's a good thing we're reducing
reliance on oil
i've worked hard these past few weeks
and calls and meetings with foreign
leaders
policymakers to put together the
building blocks for today's global
announcement
and while our combination our combined
actions will not solve the problem of
high gas prices overnight
it will make a difference
it will take time but before long you
should see the price of gas drop where
you fill up your tank
and in the longer term we will reduce
our reliance on oil as we shift to clean
energy but right now
i will do what needs to be done to
reduce the price you pay at the pump
okay by the way what did he do to reduce
the price that we pay at the pump he um
released 50 million barrels of oil from
the strategic petroleum reserve there's
only one problem with this the united
states uses about 20 million barrels of
oil every single day so he released
about two and a half days worth of oil
that's it that's that's what he did
for the entire nation
yeah that's not gonna do anything and
what's really encouraging is that uh
jennifer granholm the secretary of
energy who can be viewed in a bizarre
video singing about how we need to get
rid of gas literally singing about it
it's a very very weird video we showed
it earlier this week
she does not know how many barrels of
gas americans use a day and she has no
clue she has no having no idea how many
barrels of oil now you're the energy
secretary so i feel like you should know
this
you should have some especially on a day
that you're announcing like that that's
the number one question right if
somebody gives you a statistic
completely out of context like
joe biden released 50 million barrels of
oil you're like wow that's a lot of oil
but your very first question like
literally the first question is okay but
how many do you use on a regular day if
i said to you
today you are i'm gonna give you a
caloric allotment of
1 000 calories
without any context you might think to
yourself okay well um but how many do i
need like that's your literally your
first question is how much do i need
okay so if you release 50 million
barrels of oil
people might immediately think how much
oil do you need well here's the problem
the energy secretary doesn't know
because she's too busy focused on
tick-tocking her way through life
there are various figures about this i'm
chris if you know how many barrels of
oil does the us consume per day i don't
have that number in front of me so some
suggest it's about 18 million which
would suggest you're releasing less than
three days worth of supply from the
petroleum reserve
why is that enough
well
we what we are doing plus what other
countries may be doing
which will be less than what we're doing
because we have the largest um
amount of strategic patrol of petroleum
reserves
yeah man that would be a non-answer
right there but the good news is we're
ramping up clean energy so strap that
windmill to the top of your car and just
pinwheel your way to work today
relying upon volatile sources or relying
upon fuel from countries that may not
have our best interests at heart hurts
the american people in the long and in
the short
run so it's why we're working faster
than ever to diversify our energy to add
more clean energy it's why the
president's vision of building out clean
energy sources like solar and wind and
hydropower and geothermal and advanced
nuclear that is the answer that is the
best strategy long term to protect
american consumers from these energy
price shocks
okay you're not protecting american
consumers from bleep okay let me explain
why carbon-based energy is by far the
most efficient form of energy period end
of story it is the most efficient and
because one of the big problems with
things like wind or solar power
is that the batteries don't hold the
energy for very long okay so it turns
out that when there's no wind
that's the end of it and when there is a
rainy day that makes very difficult for
solar energy to be a thing
these alternative forms of energy are
much more expensive than gas so there's
only one way that you can actually get
people to use these alternative form of
energies and that's you got to subsidize
them now to subsidize them you have to
artificially either raise the price of
gas or you have to artificially lower
the price of these alternative forms of
energy now you can make the case for
that but you can't make that case to the
consumer okay if the case you're making
to the consumer is there will be no cost
to our policies that of course is a lie
of course there are costs to your
policies but democrats don't want you to
know their cost your policy so instead
they just lie they'll be like well we're
going to create millions of green jobs
no you're not you're not all you're
going to do is take jobs away from more
efficient industries and put them in
less efficient industries the cost of
the taxpayer that's all you're doing and
we all know it but the good news is joe
biden knows one thing and that this is
it's that this is not his fault as
always nothing is ever his fault
i also want to briefly address one myth
about inflated gas prices
they're not due to environmental
measures
my effort to combat climate change is
not raising the price of gas
or increasing its availability
in what it is doing it's increasing the
availability of jobs
jobs building electric cars like the one
i drove in the gm detroit the gm factory
in detroit last week for the hundreds of
thousands of folks who brought one of
those electric cars they're gonna save
800 to a thousand dollars in fuel costs
this year
um so uh no
okay so i'm just gonna say that that his
policies are not putting millions of
people in electric cars across the
united states
by the way at the end of 2020 the grand
total number of electric vehicles being
used in the united states little over a
million how many cars are being used
total in the united states right now
uh 287 million so no
gonna go no on that joe
alrighty well we've reached the end of
today's show however we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out our
newest podcast morning wire on today's
episode they give you some updates on
the jizzlane maxwell trial that episode
is available right now on apple spotify
or wherever you listen to podcasts so
make sure to tune in i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the galain maxwell
trial is set to begin the u.s suffers a
record number of overdose deaths and
protests protest breakout in europe over
covet restrictions
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire